Strap in, Marvel fans there's more Thor in
store.
Per The Hollywood Reporter, a fourth Thor
film is in the works.
The good news?
Thor: Ragnarok filmmaker Taika Waititi is
officially on board to write and direct Thor
4, meaning that he can continue imbuing the
film series with his signature humor, eccentric
wit, and snappy dialogue.
"This doesn't make any sense.
No, nothing makes sense here, man.
The only thing that does make sense is that
nothing makes sense."
The bad news?
Waititi singing on for another Thor film means
that the live-action adaptation of Akira is
now on hold but if you’ve been following
the development of that movie at all, what
else is new, right?
A feature film translation of Katsuhiro Otomo's
manga of the same name, Akira has been in
development for years, experiencing an upswing
in May 2019 when Waititi boarded as its director
and co-writer.
After since 2002 to get the movie off the
ground, studio Warner Bros. finally scheduled
it to debut in theaters on May 21, 2021.
Prior to joining Thor 4, Waititi was said
to be testing actors in a talent search that
spanned the globe, and things seemed to be
finally moving forward for Akira.
Unfortunately, the film is on an indefinite
hold now that Waititi is focusing on Thor
4, which will reportedly rub shoulders with
Akira's planned production start date.
With the two start dates for filming now being
so close to each other, it seems there's no
way Waititi could feasibly work on both projects.
It's unclear what will happen to Akira while
Waititi is writing and directing Thor 4, but
THR has reported that Warner Bros. intends
to keep Waititi attached to the project, apparently
on a long-term basis.
Executives are reportedly hoping that Waititi
will re-commit to Akira after he wraps the
new Thor movie.
Fortunately for everyone, Chris Hemsworth
is lined up to reprise his role as the Asgardian
god of thunder who underwent a drastic transformation
in Avengers: Endgame.
Thor's evolution from a cocky, arrogant hero
with little regard for those around him to
a kind-hearted, empathetic, funny guy who
overcomes personal struggles has impressed
viewers but the new physique he sported in
Endgame left fans divided.
Some loved "fat Thor," while others hated
him.
He never did shed any weight in Endgame, last
appearing in the film with his beer belly
and shaggy hair firmly intact, and Hemsworth
couldn't be happier about that.
He told Variety:
"I feel like we’ve opened up such a different
character.
I feel more energized for the possibility
of where it could go."
Endgame came to a close with Thor appointing
Valkyrie as the protector of New Asgard, then
joining the Guardians of the Galaxy on their
mission to locate Gamora.
It's believed that Guardians of the Galaxy
Vol. 3, which has director James Gunn back
on board, will focus on the Guardians as they
track down their green-skinned teammate, with
Thor possibly in the mix as well as an ally,
or even new member of the team.
What happens in that film could influence
the story of Thor 4.
But with Marvel Studios’ fourth phase of
the MCU being so shrouded in mystery, we truly
have zero idea what will happen in either
film.
What's interesting about Thor 4 is that it's
the first instance in which an original Avenger
is continuing their standalone franchise beyond
a trilogy.
Iron Man actor Robert Downey Jr. and Captain
America star Chris Evans each had three solo
films in addition to crossover ensembles,
and both retired their characters with Avengers:
Endgame.
"I am Iron Man."
This development begs a rather juicy question:
did Chris Hemsworth extend his contract to
more solo movies?
How many Marvel films did he commit to?
It's all very exciting to think about, as
Hemsworth's Thor has become one of the most
charismatic and naturally hilarious heroes
in the MCU, arguably only becoming a serious
fan-favorite after his jokier characterization
in Waititi’s Thor: Ragnarok.
We wouldn't mind a couple more Thor-featuring
flicks, and we doubt any other fans would
either.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superhero films are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.